This is a tricky question, and
maybe one that you had to think about pretty hard.
I would say there's only one answer.
This one.
One data set.
It would be a good candidate for linear regression.
Hopefully, you got that one.
So, what are the problems with the other ones?
Well, let's start with this one on the lower right.
It would be pretty easy to think of a function that might fit it nicely, but
this function would be something like Y equals X squared,
which is not of the form y equals mx plus b.
In other words, this isn't a line.
This is more of a curve.
There are ways that you can fit these functions, but
it wouldn't be an example of linear regression.
So that's why this would not be a good candidate for linear regression.
One possibility that's almost good for linear regression is this one.
Because you could fit it with lines but
you need two different lines to fit the pattern adequately.
In fact, if you try to fit this whole data set with one line,
it'll probably give you something like this.
A clever thing that you could do would be to split it in half along this dotted
line and fit one half of the data to one line and one half to the other one.
So if you checked that box because you're thinking something like that,
then I would say that's probably an acceptable answer.
But just as it is, there's not a single line that fits all of these data points.
So I would say that without doing something like, fitting it piece wise,
this would not be a good candidate either.
Next, let's see the data set in the top middle here.
The problem here is just that the data is all over the place.
There doesn't seem to be a very strong pattern.
So there's lots of different lines that might all have very similar r squares or
sum of square errors that could all look very different.
And in this case, it's hard to say that any of these lines is really
describing a pattern in the data very well.
So I would say this is not a particularly good candidate.
And this last one, on the upper left, is very tricky.
And if you got this one wrong, you shouldn't feel too bad because it's tough.
And the problem with this one is,
let's look back at this equation y equals mx plus b.
And what this means is that by varying along the x axis,
the input variable, I want to be able to predict something about
what the y value will be along the vertical scale.
So I only have one x value, and that's right here.
And I have many different y values all along this range.
And so there's no way just using this data.
That I can vary x and use that to predict a change in y.
Another way to say this is that when the equation tries to fit this data,
it's going to come up with infinity for m.
And usually when you get infinities, it means that something's going wrong.
This is very tricky because you definitely need to have variation in x.
Now in this case, of course, on the lower left, you only have variation in x.
You don't have any variation in y.
So in this case, the slope m would be equal to zero.
So fitting it with a line might be a little bit of overkill.
You could just say that, suppose that this is eight.
You could just say that y is always equal to eight.
And that would do a perfectly good job of describing the pattern.
But it's very important that you have a range of x values that you can examine.
So that's why this is not a good candidate for linear regression, but this is.